hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to I don't even game now I
believe this is made by the same person
that made I don't even know which kind
of seems correct cousin gentle fun food
watching by the [ __ ] feeling by the
similarity in the artistic style of it
is what I was trying to say but out came
flabby feeling either way I don't know
how to play this game because it has no
instructions but I'm gonna go write it
apparently oh hi bye you little door
okay alright bye okay hello another key
oh you lost your key to grade have you
seen I lost the key have you seen it but
you need to keep oh I'm not okay you
need a key not an key the a key
haha I've been playing games awhile and
I press the a button ended open the door
and a Z guys couldn't see that because
you couldn't see it because of my
keyboard not actually we were still
going been a while since someone came to
this part slow dancer iPod my keys oh
I'm still hoping to minis my keys get on
low oh okay bye oh I didn't mean to stay
here oh okay please walk I believe dude
I'm lady of bugs bugs bill please stand
a lot for metals Victor
[Music]
I am screaming in this guy's ear
pressing the cue button all your worries
go away the cue button drops weapons huh
you dropped a purse bomb okay goodbye hi
this bomb over there apparently hello
slow down dear Bronco this is a random
DUI test zone so I'm gonna need you say
the alphabet backwards okay all right
z Y X W V u T s are Q P o n m l k j IH g
f e d c ba got it alright alright you're
not drunk or driving yes yeah I wasn't
driving what it bother to stop I really
did like your purse though just want you
to know okay alright then yeah welcome
back to the high I tried to stop by
watching to prevent Brad weather from
happening
please wait we're gathering weather
information oh very slow waiting for the
weather it's gotta be a nice sunny day
okay no storm beginning to think this
place never ends well you might be right
about 100 try this like a million times
I'll try it a million and one badge I'll
go the other way I do honor your
commitment no I can't even go backwards
I'm gonna go forward I'm gonna go that
way see you dude knitted Shadid if she
succeeds then Pig might as well fly oh
oh I am person of cheatcodes whoever
would you say about G codes
hey hey worked again lost all the keys
can you help oops on point point got em
for you
and oh hold on to your key your four key
or I gave me with my four button I did
it it was great please watch your step
ahead residential area yeah okay good
bye
no I don't babysit here's to baby in
about four years I'll be back here again
don't leave until then okay excuse you
why do I have to wait four years here I
don't know Oh shook you drop the baby
word it to baby Cole
it seems irresponsible but here I go I
drop my sword move along nothing to see
here
okay goodbye okay hi hello goodbye
farewell hello stop there young one no
needs to hurry mu K to pass you must do
one very leat thing you must show me to
number one ninja rule um very nice
formed you to number one rule is
patience in silence ah do you may pass
due has done well do quit pets but don't
get involved with a pirates oh yeah this
is back in the day when the internet was
obsessed with pirates vs. ninjas I was
always a pirate type
where hasn't monster problems welcome to
pirate hospital okay goodbye hello
goodbye hello
Oh two points I died
hello bye hello hello hello goodbye
why do you hope to see me again that
seems awfully mean you're counting on a
lot of things that I don't like here and
I don't appreciate okay hey let me ask
you you actually is a pilot no no I'm
not I'm not I know I can dance does that
help
does that help you believe that I'm a
pirate wait what is this down here
currently on level 51 I don't know what
that means achievements I don't know
what that means oh that's a lot of
achievements [ __ ] are know oh that was
it I just had to press our show me the
best pirate growl Joo has our hey you're
legit but I've always wondered this what
is this shape of a doughnut r oh I
supposed to confess very interesting
knowledge facts oh thank you thank you
very much you have a good day now raids
going just keep an eye on your sanity
you mean like amnesia don't walk the
next screen you'll lose progress
I don't care
the end is near that's good notice how
you can never turn back yeah I did never
look back [ __ ] you always stay
looking forward and into the future
please ignore all ghosts and ghost land
okay alright then okay alright hello are
you a ghost no see I've been cursed boo
at the freight and you shall pass you a
bunch of other [ __ ] letters on the
keyboard on push o one why did that do
ok goodbye ghost Birds not real okay
I'm a ghost change your controls mortal
which way did you come here I go
I don't know what I pressed but I
started going yeah I go to the greatest
racer in all the ghost lands ok but
you're not from here alright I'll be to
win you beat me you [ __ ]
Oh gonna pay off million dollars the
look on your face says Joo has info I
need what is 230 lives code
I really must is that the Konami code up
up down down left right left right beat
eight oh there we go
I've been stuck on that game for her to
ever we'll see you then
seriously going to talk to the king he's
pretty he is 10 angry he plans to
control off to ghost lands oh well good
glad I'm here who are please don't
threat on to King's garden Weaver worked
for hours and hours dude okay very good
Walt who going there it'd be your
brother back from the dead in the land
of the living
well you're still in the land of the
dead because you're a ghost [ __ ]
what are you doing in my Gardens and in
the face no time for - I'm taking
controller - Ghost Lance - Lance - under
the old controls you cannot control you
cannot control I can't control
Oh control ha ha ha I press the control
button what has to do curse these
mortals 1 1 1 all right goodbye
i new king thanks for ok nor ghost lamps
Tea Party 4 do guys happy
- careful bad things happen along this
way bad things have been happening to me
the whole way please notice Julie's
entering restricted area stop please
turn around now please go away
I can't I literally can only go forward
so limited options here restricted I am
to automated entry but to pass you must
answer a series of questions please
answer yes or no do not consume bagels
over-mighty Assis are you allowed to
enter this facility yes oh are you not
allowed to enter this facility no I see
would you like to walk away from this
facility no ok do you want to get into
this facility a lot right yep even if I
just stole all of your cookies yes sir
well dude you not not not not not want
to go inside I'm gonna go with no arrow
reset ah [ __ ] yes do you do not hate
this facility right yes do you want to
go in this facility yes
oh you're I didn't see your sarcasm tag
[ __ ] do you want to go in this facility
no dude you not ok
[Music]
nope
haha what does to word no bondo bead no
start with well that was painless you
matter the facility okay goodbye yeah
though would you say about bagels
please welcome to yourself to Cinetopia
labs what wait how did you get in here
don't go to row goes we'll find you all
right that sounds good
you're not real am i right I don't know
it seemed pretty real all this time and
activity is making me crazy
Jude err human halt no human slave stop
right there stop this unit refuses to
stand for your resistance all you
dispatcher attention please please
accept her to scape flava
wait squadron to slave is right there
stop your journey ends here and now you
has made a mess here and I is
unsatisfied now I'm a sent you back to
which belong walked away all the way
back in time
oh excuse you
aha I knew it it was a lie so what they
threatened wasn't it true truly nothing
can dampen your world this cretians knew
all okay please hold on to but firmly
entering the reactor core my but gonna
melt off for radiation
reactor core access denied non robot
override is disabled please hold refer
to law code blog directory at low law
old board okay ah Mac that website
doesn't exist anymore that's how old
this game is I don't know what the code
is okay wait wait wait wait whoa whoa
everybody hold on to your butts we just
got in the reactor core and things are
about to get lit up in here I think I
know the code I think this is in I'm
pretty sure boink yay access to non
remote override approved fragmenting
sector simulation access granted okay
cool I don't know what that means I
don't know what any of that means but
I'm down
that see a baby oh this is to insanity
we should make you run for the exit
people oh okay I always told you to the
grass is greener over here Oh
remember me press Q fur and tasty brew
what was beyond it though
Louis beyond the lemonade stand and what
was that frame I saw what was that there
there was something there I saw
something I saw it what was that you
can't hide anything read your big my
brain is like skulls huge mother brain
[ __ ] tiny little gerbil in my head
wounded about but that means I'm smart I
think I don't know catch a secret
sailing salmon avoid annoying things
twice complete the game within a certain
time complete the vain game as a veteran
witness egg media three times in one
game by using right quick two men you
would have fail read every snippet of
dialogue in the game in one game no it's
not find the bunker just cuz I'm crazy I
want to go back I wanna I want to do it
all again I just I'm absolutely out of
my mind going through the game now
Scootaloo do present in the a key
Scootaloo do walking over here now it's
good Lee do oh no there's my key studio
[Music]
baby Dooley little little Jo lovers
friends gonna drop me when it comes to
dumb I do little little drop the burst
and I'm still going there get out of my
way you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
Lulu booboo and we made it we made it
back okay so I'm gonna carry on here let
me boy I got stuck early lose but I
still got here faster didn't it look
next time hobbledehoy I was literally as
fast
I could I don't know how I could have
gotten here faster all right whatever
well that's how long it took literally
less than half the time it took me
before but even I guess that was just
too long then it's probably close oh
it's probably close I just don't know
how close but either way that is on an
even game I love these things they're a
blast from the past and I'm not not even
like that far back in fact when I was
first going into college the game came
out which is really weird to think about
because there were games that I remember
playing back when I was in high school
oh my god ancient ancient ancient stuff
but good stuff nonetheless so thank you
everybody so much for watching I really
hope you enjoyed this one if you want
try to get all the achievements for
yourself I'll put a link to this game in
the description so thanks again and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]